[موسيقى]
الممارسه الرياضيه المستمره ومتابعه دعم
غذائي صحي هم اساس العلاج اساس فقدان
الوزن واساس الحفاظ على وزن مثالي ولكن
الكثير ممن ياتون لكي يقومون بعمليه
جراحيتك للمعده او تحويل مسار المعده او
وضع بالون المعده هم اشخاص جربوا هذه
الاشياء جربوا متابعه غذائيه جربوا ممارسه
الرياضه ولكنهم وهناك دراسه في امريكا
التي تقول بان 20% فقط من الاشخاص الذين
اتخذوا قرار ممارسه الرياضيه ومتابعه
الحميه هم الذين ينجحون في فقدان الوزن
على مدار السنه و80% يفشلون في ذلك على
المدى الطويل لان هناك نظريه تسمى
او نظريه النقطه المحدده التي تقول بان
الجسم يقوم بكل ما في وسعه لكي يحافظ على
وزنه الطبيعي وزن الطبيعي يعني الوزن الذي
هو فيه فالذي يعاني من السمنه الذي لديه
مؤشر كتله الجسم مرتفع جدا الجسم يتعود
على هذه الكتله الدهنيه لانه يعتبرها
كماده اساسيه او ماده مقدسه لا يجب
المسافه بها
[موسيقى]
ليست هناك عمليات امنه مئه بالمئه كل
عمليات الجراحيه الا ولها مثلا عمليه
الختان فهناك وفاه في كل خمسين الف عمليه
ختان يعني بصفر فاصله صفر صفر صفر صفر
اثنان بالمئه حتى عمليات انقاص الوزن سليب
فهناك
يعني 0.3 بالمئه لكن السمنه تزيد حسب
جامعه
تزيد باربعين في المئه من نسبه الوفاه
بالمقارنه مع عامه الناس الذين لا يعانون
من الزياده في الوزن ولا يعانون من السمنه
وهناك اكثر من ثلاث ملايين شخص يموتون
بالسمنه كل سنه فكان مضاعفات عمليات انقاص
الوزن هو خمسه بالمئه نزيف مثلا او تعفن
او شيء من هذا القبيل فان مضاعفات السمنه
فهي مضاعفات خطيره جدا
[موسيقى]
هناك الكثير من العوامل التي تؤدي الى
انتشار السمنه بشكل مخيف جدا في العالم
لان نعتبرها جائحه فالسمنه تعتبر كخامس
عامل للوفاه في العالم وهذا الانتشار يعود
الى الكثير من الاشياء حاول ان اذكر خمس
عوامل مهمه ادت الى انتشار السمنه في
العالم العامل الاول هو تغيير نمط الحياه
تغير الذي طرا على نمط حياه الانسان انسان
الان بدا ياكل ارضيه مصنعه ذات سعرات
حراريه عاليه تحتوي على كربوهيدرات مكرره
على حساب الاكل الصحي بالاضافه ايضا الى
تغير العمل الذي اصبح عمل في المكاتب
فالانسان كان يزاول جهد بدني في عمله طيله
القرون الماضيه الان هو جالس فقط في
المكتب لا يقوم بالجهد البدني الضروري لكي
ينقص الوزن العامل الثالث هو انه في اوقات
الراحه فالانسان يفضل على انه يشاهد
مسلسلات او افلام او مباريات او انه يمضي
الوقت على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي عوض
انه يذهب الى صلاه الرياضه الامر الرابع
هو اضطرابات النوم
والاضطرابات النفسيه المتزايده التي نراها
بكثره
لكي نحارب هذه الجائحه هو العوده الى نمط
الحياه الصحي يعني تغذيه صحيه سليمه
ممارسه الرياضه بشكل مستمر والاعتناء
بالصحه النفسيه وكذلك التحسيس والتوعيه
بمخاطر السمنه بالمضاعفات التي تنجم عنها
السمنه وكذلك وهو شيء مهم جدا ان نعتبر
السمنه كمرض وليس اختياري